boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan saki and
we are at the transformative technology
conference we are now sitting down with
boris and mike from conscious what's up
guys how's it going alan thank you for
coming on the show and talking to me
appreciate it good to meet you yeah yeah
it's such a pleasure i'm excited to talk
about this um this so-called uh this
wireless bio feedback system that can
help increase states self-awareness i'm
really excited to talk about this um
before that let's talk about who you
guys are so how did you guys even get to
the point that you're at today
i think maybe mike can kick us off with
that one cool i'll start so um about
four years ago i was an entrepreneur
working at lululemon in their tech
department and basically um i ended up
leaving there because it was less
meditation and yoga and too much work so
i ended up becoming an entrepreneur and
deep dove into two specific uh kind of
jobs or industries one was romance
publishing so publishing books about
romance i didn't tell the pink shirt you
know yeah yeah yeah i honestly know
nothing about that in industry it's just
business
i became one of the top romance
publishers in the world at one point um
and then i dove into e-commerce and
ended up being one of the top facebook
marketers in the world i was spending
about 30 to 50 000 a day on facebook
advertising and so i made a lot of money
in that and now
here is conscious and essentially the
vision of conscious came to me as i was
meditating with boris down in uh l.a i
think at the time about eight months ago
and i had this vision of really just
liberating people on all levels and what
that means is
paying people to essentially meditate
and be rather than do
and so this is our passion project and
now we're working on it full-time so
okay
okay cool cool boris let's hear about
yours i have a lot of questions
yeah
so yeah my background uh coming you know
from my professional background is in
psychotherapy so
ever since um
ever since i kind of started diving into
this understanding of how do we
you know how do we heal and how do we
optimize the human experience it really
grabbed me and so i went through various
different trainings healing modalities
looking into body work looking into
breath work looking into neurofeedback
and seeing what what is it that really
makes for
that liberated human experience
when mike went into e-commerce i kind of
followed him uh
down that path and we both had some
really great success in e-commerce um
but it was also very um draining for me
because that had nothing to do at all
with what
my calling is what i felt i was here for
and so
you know when when this opportunity came
about when these ideas started to kind
of um
ripen in in our minds it was very
exciting to just dive in and to really
serve from the heart and to put all of
our skills to use
yeah yeah
oh this is awesome okay so
all right so it seems as though you know
a lot of entrepreneurship uh a lot of
high-tech sort of figuring out the
cutting-edge tech stuff a lot of
psychotherapy um and then so then this
this moment of aha we're gonna start to
pay people to do to be instead of do
all right how does one get paid to just
be yeah so this is kind of the initial
concept of why this vision came to be
since then it's obviously just like any
startup taking a lot of twists and turns
now
the ability to pay people comes with
cryptocurrency in the blockchain so as
you know for the first time in human
history with the blockchain we're able
to create shared value economies and
what that means is if mean you share a
value in this case let's say we say
meditation is valuable or alleviating
stress is valuable then we should be
rewarded in some way shape or form and
so now we can literally just create some
sort of trust mechanism between me and
you and then we can flow currency or
cryptocurrency back and forth and so
this trust mechanism and this is how we
kind of gotten the quantified self
movement
was how do you determine if somebody's
meditating so we went down that path and
we found the key metric which is hrv
um so then we started looking at
quantifying itself essentially so the so
the hrv ends up being more varied when
someone is meditating rather than
correct i believe it goes into higher
states of
there's a picture of patterns so yeah
when you analyze oh sorry
yeah this is the same there's a couple
of patterns so when you analyze um hrv
on the power spectrum you can see
um
you can see specific frequencies light
up one is called the meditator's peak so
when somebody's actually meditating you
can see that in the change in their
physiological uh biomarkers which ones
are you measuring specifically so
specifically it's hrv and so as well as
said the meditator's peak is when you're
doing an analysis of hiv on on when you
plot it on a graph you can see a very
distinct
signature and a person is meditating
what's happening in their heart when
they're coming into a meditative state
and that meditative peak is that because
i've seen some of these uh analyses
before and yeah there's for sure a
distinct peak
now is that distinct peak
is that a state of them really getting
to a a peak of what would you say that
is this is a really good question so
this peak is associated with a state
called um popularly it's called
coherence scientifically it's called uh
respiratory sinus arrhythmia which
sounds like a disease
respiratory sinus arrhythmia which means
that your breath um and your heart are
synchronizing into a coherent singular
wave that starts to entrain this starts
to entrain your entire body and all of
your organ systems so your body comes
into the most efficient state both in
terms of your mental performance and
your physiology interesting so
respiratory sinus arrhythmia
means that my breath and my heart are
coming into sync and therefore my
physiology my all my organs are kind of
they're all synced they're just
coherence rather than the
the high beta just
running around just blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah stuff and that way
there's no real real rhythm when you're
doing that versus so that peak is that
is that state of complete coherence or
rhythm that you can have as it's like a
cadence a life cadence almost if you can
keep that as long as possible throughout
your life then you can
likely
live longer healthier happier uh and be
more kind to people there's lots of yeah
good things that come from this so okay
so that's like a lot on the science yeah
i wanted to just tag on to what's one
thing there's one more important
correlation when this state occurs when
we can see this hiv marker and that's
that at that point um the brain also
goes into alpha so as you are starting
to mention like this kind of a rhythmic
beta so when we start to see coherence
we actually start to see heart brain
coherence as well so we really have that
peak it's the underlying physiological
state of flow yes that's what happens
when we start to feel really in the
moment really tuned in yes yes
now
all right let's go back to the
blockchain stuff so and then actually i
also want to talk about the uh bio
feedback how you're actually connect
collecting it wirelessly so
onto the blockchain stuff quick um
give me the breakdown of why
i how i meditate i accrue some sort of
currency that has some sort of worth and
there's some sort of accountability
between people to to be so yeah let's
let's unpack that sure yeah so i mean
the blockchain right now as many people
know is in a weird state especially
cryptocurrency where we had that huge
rush last year and we see many projects
get funded and then instantly fail or
shut down so
we are taking a safer approach and i i
recommend this for any startup company
right now is really to create an economy
where you have a large amount of users
our goal is one million users to start
that are going through your in-game
economy
gamification token or uh basically your
points system
and ensuring that that is sustainable
before you implement blockchain into it
because what we're seeing is people are
launching these icos
um with poor tokenomics models that are
not sustainable uh and then it's just
it's not just not gonna last so really
you need to create a real core company
have blockchain in the back of your mind
yeah and stay on top of it and then
when it comes time you just turn it on
so you're a centralized ledger for the
first 100 a year or two or whatever it
requires until you get the million um
users that are frequently using the
platform and then you see you've proved
your concept and then you can
decentralize it
and you can move slowly towards
decentralization yeah we still don't
believe in a fully decentralized system
um especially in this wellness space we
don't think it's it's
maybe it's not even necessary at this
point interesting other markets because
why financial markets yeah yeah well
you're not trying to capitalize on
people meditating you're you're just
trying to help people meditate yeah
there's
yeah i guess that it can make sense okay
and ideally i think in the in the next
year or two or maybe five years we'll
start to see
um specifically blockchains related to
wellness and right now we're not really
seeing we have one-off projects like
high-five network which are paying
people to meditate also um we have
shivoham which is storing dna on the
blockchain and stuff like that but
really nobody's proven anything at this
point so it's really too early and this
is why we've we've taken the concept of
blockchain put it in our documents
letting people know that this is on our
radar but we're not going to turn it on
until maybe next year we'll see how the
market goes but okay and then let's go
back to the wireless biofeedback system
so how are you collecting hrv wirelessly
yeah so in the beginning we also
just as you see at this conference you
see that many people are creating these
different wearables um different things
to
basically have
a sort of hardware that you interact
with the the product through and this is
what we were thinking too in the
beginning but when we started to do more
research we realized that there is
technology available technology really
comes under the name of computer vision
so computer vision is a way of using
cameras just like the cameras we have
here
but
pulling them through
signal processing algorithms that filter
it to such a extent that for example
when i look at you i can't see your
pulse totally right but um computer
vision can through filtering in a
certain way we can actually see how the
blood goes up each time your heart beats
it flushes your face if it's that acute
right if it's got to be really sensitive
it's well pick up even the like
commercial uh consumer level cell phone
front-facing camera can do it so it's
really more about the filtering
algorithms um what it's really doing is
it's looking at the minute change in
color on the pixels that are
representing your face on the on the
video stream and when you magnify those
when you magnify the difference our eyes
can pick up the difference but when the
computer is magnified then you can see
very distinctly flush flush
mm-hmm and so we can that's really
distinct i mean that's a very my new
difference it's it's such a hard
distinction to make
that if i that's a really sensitive
technology that would have to pick that
up it's just it's just interesting to me
that this is now coming out with even a
front-facing camera on a stock cell
phone that can yeah they can do that
it's very accurate
94 accuracy compared to ecg or ekg which
is the gold standard for measuring four
percent of the front-facing camera yeah
hmm whoa yeah it's cool
it's pretty crazy so that really frees
us up from having to have that barrier
to entry of having to buy more hardware
hardware and wear it yeah so you can use
any computer or any
tablet or any cell phone to actually
practice and to get feedback that you're
really getting progress that something's
really happening you're not just sitting
there listening to a playlist but you're
really seeing that things are changing
as you are training or meditating yeah
yeah
interesting
um
damn so
so then
okay so you're wirelessly collecting it
so then you con so i would download
conscious is that how i would do this
and then okay so i would download
conscious and are you on both stores
right now so we haven't launched yet but
the way that we are launching is that
there is this underlying core technology
of contactless biofeedback that's really
its goal is to optimize for stress
reduction that's what it's essentially
looking for so as you come closer to the
flow state of course
the corollaries that you're coming out
of stress states
right so um what we're going to be doing
is we're going to be launching it as
multiple applications one is going to be
a multiplayer meditation application and
another one is coming under the umbrella
of conscious games where you're going to
use the same exact mechanism except now
we can put it into
categories such as kids games where
simply that you know they're progressing
on the screen based on very simple
exercises to get them into a little bit
of a higher coherence so they're
learning self-regulation as they're
playing
okay so
for for now you've just tested the
technology and tested your your games
and your your processes with with people
and then
you're aiming to launch this
soon
yeah
yeah we're we're
i'm not sure it was definitely be in
2019 so right now we have the prototypes
ready we're optimizing them for accuracy
we're
kind of putting the skins and the beauty
around them because this is a very
important aspect totally be able to
present something beautiful polished and
clean yeah yeah
okay
and
there were there were things there were
things you just mentioned this both this
group
this group meditation um and this
gamification of modern meditation so
what would that what would that look
like for for me to
turn
unconscious on my phone and then to
just prop it up against the wall and
just sit there in front on a cushion in
front of the front-facing camera and
just meditate and then accrue
points and in-game points that could
potentially be useful for
something as long as other people found
them valuable
yeah do you want to see more on this or
do you want me to keep going i'm using a
library on the two other products
which might give them one yeah yeah so
this is important yeah so we have two
other products which might give you a
better use case and really since we are
we have four products on the roadmap
we're really looking for our investors
who are opening a seed round of two
million dollars at this point um to give
us guidance and really see which one of
these products our attention should
really focus on one of the products
which boris didn't mention was um
something called the conscious plugin
which is essentially a plug-in in your
browser which will allow you to then see
what you're consuming on the internet
and how that's affecting your your
nervous system essentially right so
people can start to see let's say
they're on facebook for an hour and they
start to see their coherence levels
start to go down well then we can warn
them in real time right so that would be
a probably a bigger use case for the
masses that's kind of interesting can
you use the front-facing camera on the
laptop yeah exactly and it's more stable
than the smartphone right so there's
certain challenges um we are getting it
to a point where we have motion
detection so it's very accurate so even
if you are kind of moving the smartphone
it should still be able to track it
accurately
damn i wonder what percentage of
time spent on
social media actually increases
coherence versus decreasing totally and
this is what we're seeing in in the kind
of cultural trend right that people are
becoming more and more aware of what
they're consuming fake news all this
stuff um
so just making it people more aware of
it yeah quantifiably yeah
yeah it's actually quite rare that i
think i
i leave
the social platforms
feeling more coherent
i think it's it's it's
the only times i leave it feeling more
coherent i guess is when i see that you
know maybe the dalai lama tweeted
something and then i really liked the
tweet and i retweeted it or whatever and
then i got off the platform right away
something like that right
yeah you spend just a minute on it and
you know you go and see someone that
said something about someone's you know
like that they're so grateful for
something and then you're like oh that's
great and then you're really grateful
for a moment and then you get off the
platform so like that's like really good
experiences but whenever you see the the
fire fights that are going on and stuff
that's
never increases gratitude it never
increases coherence it's just
yeah it's just a fire fight
we're really riding a huge wave and
we're not the only ones right we just
saw apple's releasing some headphones
that start to track um your hiv just
using the headphones so they'll be able
to link that too music playing or
whatever and seeing how that your
conceptual music
that's interesting so is that their next
iteration of those wireless headphones
tim was showing us that yesterday with
the headphones that had
sensors in them for but he wasn't doing
hrv he was doing
measuring neural activity around that
region and then
it seems as though we are
all of the companies are trying to move
to a place where they have additional
data to work with so uh biomarker data
so
okay what's the fourth one that was
those three you've listed now so it's
the fourth one the fourth one is a
workplace app so just like many people
are working on corporate sas products um
we also have that in the roadmap and
that just makes sense although based on
a lot of the uh feedback from the
program a lot of people are saying don't
go down the b to c route first start
with ours don't go down to the b the b
route start with b to c yeah get a wide
net and then go b to b
so what do you what do you quickly just
what would you um
go through go through all four one more
time again sure so we got the
multiplayer meditation app
we have something called conscious games
and then we have the conscious plugin
and the conscious workplace app and the
difference between the first two again
is
the meditation app and the games
so the meditation app is really for
people that are using let's say
headspace and calm existing meditators
maybe we'll catch some new meditators
just with
a lot of the uniqueness of our product
and then conscious games is you can
think of it like so we can explain one
of the games which is on our own map
which is called beautiful minds and
essentially you're using your coherence
levels to open a flower
yeah that's right so that targets people
that may not necessarily be interested
in meditation per se but they're
interested in maybe the novelty or if
something beautiful opening yeah
yeah we um also just talked to um peter
freer from free logic and he's he has a
meditation game where it's about
coherence opening a flower beautifully
yeah yeah
huh and there's so many use cases it
doesn't have to be around mindfulness
too we can race
rocket ships for example using yeah
to the moon or whatever so again our
goal is to reach a billion people just
like many companies here yeah and with
our marketing backgrounds we think we
can do that and just widen that's right
yeah the
the science mixed with the business is
very important to actually get it out to
people you know
i guess one thing that i'm starting to
realize is that
there's this there's this trend that
occurs with
companies that i
have the opportunity to
to discuss with or or mentor and one of
them is for example at indie bio which
is the largest seed stage biotech
accelerator
when i'm talking to entrepreneurs there
a lot of them are building out some sort
of a
a therapy to some sort of a problem
within the human body and that they want
to solve that problem
take example like cancer or whatnot and
i'm constantly trying to press them to
find what is the golden solution like
what is the thing that could potentially
wipe it all away
and with this there's a lot of silver
keys being developed in a sense and so i
think that might same thing might be
true about transformative technology
there might be a lot of silver keys
being produced which is great because
we're learning we're figuring things out
um there's different markets for
different things and i just i do feel
there is some sort of a gold standard
for
transformers technology for
for edging people closer towards
coherence that has yet to be i guess
manifested and scaled to a billion
people but it could be you guys it could
be
the some of the other people that we've
talked to could be how you guys share
information and share communities that
they get there it's all that's that's
just a repeating pattern that i guess
i'm seeing and that it's it's
interesting to me because it goes across
these
different
nodal networks of of impact across
sciences or yeah fields i love it boris
and i were talking about that on the
walk here is essentially it doesn't
matter what the
the how is it just matters that we set
our our vision really and have faith
that it's gonna happen and the
technologies like you said the silver
keys will appear yeah and yeah we'll be
able to solve this so yeah boris you
wanted to say anything about that yeah i
mean
one thing that i just wanted to rift off
of what you were sharing is like what
are we doing here as humanity right
because you're talking about this golden
key right this golden thread that ties
everything together
we're all trying to solve problems but
what is that core that is like what's
that
wellspring from which all the problems
are sprouting and we're like okay i'm
gonna get this one and this one and this
one and you get that one but what is
that and so you know this is kind of how
we also in this inception of this
company we're thinking about this
more as a movement like what is it that
we actually need to change for humanity
to be different right and so we started
looking at what is the commonality of
the core commonality is that we all want
to be happy we are all seeking a better
feeling right okay so but what's
happening day to day we know exactly we
actually heard this in the conference we
know what to do science tells us all the
time if you do this and this and this
you will be better yeah we don't do this
these things so what is it that's
blocking us day to day that is not
allowing us to feel the gratitude that
we know we can't feel to meditate to go
out for a walk in nature to to commune
with um with our loved ones right what's
stopping us and so what do you think's
stopping us yeah so this is this is it
so like in in public speak if we say
something that is very easy for everyone
to understand i would say that it's
stress it's essentially stress
if we can go down levels we can talk
about it more as
really it's
a lack of self-awareness
like we're just not aware of what we're
doing what is it that like what it like
taking this action will create what
results we don't really know we think we
do but then oh it turns out wrong and
it's also the secondary part of it is
lack of self-regulation like again it's
we have all of the tools to apply it
right the emotion is happening inside of
our body you're not making me feel any
way this is the fundamental reality is
it's proven by science it's been taught
you know through the wisdom traditions
nobody's making you feel any kind of way
the feelings are sprouting here based on
your how you're reacting to your own
sensations now what if we start to train
and put attention on this area and we
start to say wait a minute if i am the
source of my
happiness of my feelings of how i feel
well then maybe this is uh an area to
focus instead of focusing out there what
can i do to change out there so i feel
better what if i change something in
here and i feel tremendous what if i
discovered that wellspring within me
and this is essentially you know what
we're building this technology around
whether it's you know contactless
biofeedback or something else that comes
along in the future it doesn't matter
what matters is
how do we
um point
attention to this area for for the
greater
human collective so that we can start to
really make some difference at the
causal level instead of at the level of
all the different effects that sprout
from here
yeah yeah you point to something that i
found really interesting you said
that if you could make an easy word to
describe it would be stress what's
holding us back from coherence and i
like that it's really simple
and
self-aware the lack of self-awareness
those those two things together
it makes it makes a lot of sense
and then
so i just came back from my fourth
10-day meditation retreat the pashana
yeah yeah and so you know when you
realize that you
are
the sensation happens and then you react
or you observe and then you kind of like
you start understanding that you are the
source of how you feel and everything to
the to the outside world and then
when when you kind of start mastering
that process
what's nice is that then it makes it so
that you can vibrate on a state of bliss
no matter really what's going on around
you and then
then
if we can build the communities around
the world that also help so that when a
children's born they don't have to be
born into stress they can be born into a
community that helps the child get the
the inward growth and flourishing so
so yeah
all right so
it seems like you know we covered a
decent amount of of conscious so you're
going to be using the front-facing
camera on either a cell phone or
computer and you're going to be
having people play either group
meditations or they're going to be
playing individual games or they're
going to be you're going to be observing
their browser activities you're going to
be using blockchain technologies down
the line i'm going to be building up
this base through really strong
marketing um you're gonna have your own
uh
value currency that people can exchange
what are they gonna be able to use that
for
yeah so this is again
as you see what we're doing here is
we're taking it step by step and
experimenting since we're both coming
from the background of marketing like
our mind always goes to like a b testing
market survey like what is actually
going on what do people actually want
and how what are they using and not
using so one um
very basic use case i would say is
this app sweatcoin right sweatcoin have
you heard of it no i don't think so it
went up to number one in europe and the
states on the top free apps
okay and what it is is it's a walking
app now we've had step counters for how
many years now like a decade right or
more yeah okay so why is this happening
now what they've done and they're not a
blockchain they're also experimenting
and playing in this field but the each
time you walk they give you a portion of
a sweat coin which is like a
cryptocurrency but it's not it's not a
true cryptocurrency it's just an in-game
you know
it's just like in any other game what do
you do with the sweat coins and so what
you can do is they have their partner
offers so for example you can um perhaps
if muse is on there you can say okay
maybe a month subscription of muse you
can get for free so or
you know
they have other things other different
um since their focus is on
like a salad chain and you can exactly
you see different like health foods you
see different athletic gear different
things like this that are relevant to
that demographic so so you're basically
trading steps for the other value in in
the world yeah so that's that's pretty
cool okay so then would you be similar
to that so we could explore we can start
exploring a similar model so we have
partners um for example that host
retreats so offerings at least partial
scholarship to the retreats as you're
meditating right things that are
relevant to people and also connecting
with yoga studios connecting with so
this is kind of looking at a mutual
network um the mutually beneficial
network that can support both you know
the client and our partners and um and
ourselves to be able to offer something
really cool
what's it called what's your coin called
conscious os what's the coin called
i think in the beginning again we can
just call it conscious coin we had it
cool yeah we had it as wisdom coin in
the beginning i like that that's cool is
there something else about conscious
that we should know as we
finish up our conversation
this is where i like to close my eyes
and just meditate on
something you should know about
conscious
you're going to start to see it
everywhere
is i think you're going to start to see
it everywhere and it's going to be
beautiful and it's going to be so
beautiful that you're going to want to
try it for sure so i think just be on
the lookout you can check out
consciousos.com
um yeah links in the bio yeah yeah check
them out awesome nice i i do see that i
do see that i see a very bright future
of more aware less stressed communities
yeah
flourishing
it's a beautiful place transform
technology conference beautiful people
like yourselves thank you for what
you're working on so blessed thank you
so much yeah
um and this has been this has been a lot
of fun i really appreciate you guys
thanks for worries mike thank you thank
you both thank you yeah
um all right thanks everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it give us your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know what you're thinking about what
this technology could look like what we
could do by decreasing stress around the
world and increasing self-awareness and
go and create go and build the future go
manifest your dreams into the world much
love everyone cheers